***
Okkultismus-Nazis!
Amerikanische Nazis!
Und NASA-Nazis!
Hitler made mistakes.
With this I'll correct them all.
In den "Indiana Jones"-Filmen
sehen wir skurrile Darstellungen
der Nationalsozialisten
und ihrer Taten.
Das wirkt wie Hollywood-Spinnerei.
Da ist mehr dran, als ihr denkt.
*Filmmusik "Indiana Jones"*
Tag zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Harrison Ford bekommt es
in seinem 5. "Indiana Jones"-Film,
dem hoffentlich letzten Teil,
erneut mit Nazis zu tun.
I'm retiring.
Diesmal geht es um nichts Geringeres
als die Mondlandung.
Bei der sollen Hitler-Schergen
ihre Finger im Spiel haben.
Ist das alles Quatsch?
Wie realistisch sind die Nazis
in den Filmen dargestellt?
Das klären wir
mit dem Historiker Mirko Drotschmann.
Bevor es losgeht,
ein kleiner Disclaimer:
Wir machen
keine klassische Geschichtsstunde,
sondern checken Filmszenen.
Zu dem gesamten historischen Kontext
rund um den Nationalsozialismus
haben wir euch Videos von Mirko
in die Info-Box gepackt.
Yes, Sir!
Los geht es mit den Indy-Filmen,
streng chronologisch.
Die Nazis begegnen uns gleich
in "Jäger des verlorenen Schatzes".
*Fanfaren-Musik*
In Teil 1 sind die Nazis
auf der Suche nach der "Bundeslade".
Das jüdische Heiligtum beinhaltet
eine geheimnisvolle Macht,
die ganze Armeen
unbesiegbar machen soll.
Das klingt nach Hollywood.
Aber die Bundeslade dachten sich
Spielberg & Co. nicht aus.
Ihre Existenz
ist zumindest biblisch überliefert.
Der Kultgegenstand soll u.a.
die 2 Steintafeln
mit den 10 Geboten beinhalten.
Im 1. Film
finden die Nazis die Bundeslade.
Sie entfesseln ihre Macht
in einem Ritual.
Aber Mirko, sag mal:
Okkulte Nazis,
gab es so etwas wirklich?
Das klingt irgendwie schräg.
Und das ist es auch.
Der NS-Staat
lehnte alles Okkulte offiziell ab.
Schon 1933 wurden okkultistische
und etliche religiöse Bewegungen
als staatsfeindliche Sekten
eingestuft.
Es gab harte Strafen.
Viele kamen sogar
ins Konzentrationslager.
Der traurige Höhepunkt der Maßnahmen
war die "Sonderaktion Heß".
1941 wurden dabei
bis zu 1.000 Menschen verhaftet.
Dass die Sonderaktion so heißt,
ist kein Zufall.
Das bringt uns zur Frage zurück:
Die Verhaftungswelle folgte
auf eine ziemliche krude Aktion
von Rudolf Heß,
dem Stellvertreter von Adolf Hitler.
Der flog 1941
auf eigene Faust nach England.
Er wollte mit dem Anführer
der englischen Friedensbewegung,
Douglas-Hamilton, sprechen.
Weil ihn 2 persönliche Horoskope
dazu ermutigt hatten.
Hat er selber gesagt.
- What?
Ihr habt richtig gehört:
Ein hochrangiger Nazi
ließ seine Politik
von Horoskopen beeinflussen.
Er war nicht allein
mit seiner Faszination fürs Okkulte.
Heinrich Himmler
war fasziniert vom Neuheidentum.
Das beinhaltet Tieropfer und Rituale
zur Zwergen- und Elfenbeschwörung.
Er leitete sogar
eine Expedition nach Finnland,
um dort
heidnische Gesänge aufzuzeichnen.
Er fertigte auch Illustrationen
von heidnischen Ritualen an.
Das ist wirklich
sehr kurios und skurril.
Auch Adolf Hitler selbst
hielt sich für ein
von der Vorsehung ausgewähltes Wesen.
Während des Ersten Weltkriegs
habe er eine Stimme gehört,
die ihn
aus dem Schützengraben zitierte.
Danach sei der Graben
von einer Granate getroffen
und alle Kameraden Hitlers
getötet worden.
Von da an war Hitler überzeugt,
für etwas Großem vorbestimmt
und überirdisch beschützt zu sein.
Diese Geschichte ist nie passiert.
Hitler war Meldegänger
und leistete im Regimentsstab
hinter der Front seinen Dienst.
Es hat ihm aber geholfen,
den Kult um sich selbst zu pushen.
Wir halten fest:
Okkulte Nazis gab es tatsächlich.
Aber, Mirko,
haben die an die Bundeslade geglaubt
und danach gesucht?
Die Nationalsozialisten suchten
aktiv nach religiösen Artefakten.
Wesentlich für den Anfang
vom "Jäger des verlorenen Schatzes"
war diese Idee:
Die Nazis
senden eine Expedition in die Anden.
Genau das haben sie gemacht.
Weil Himmler überzeugt war,
dass das bolivianische Tiwanaku
Kolonie der Arier aus Atlantis war.
Die Nationalsozialisten
suchten ebenfalls den Heiligen Gral,
wie in "Indiana Jones
und der letzte Kreuzzug".
1935 beauftragte Himmler
in einem geheimen Treffen
den Schriftsteller und SS-Mann
Otto Rahn mit der Suche.
Die Idee,
dass Nazis die Bundeslade suchten,
ist nicht weit hergeholt.
Aber wir können sicher sagen,
dass sie sie nie gefunden haben.
Wir halten fest:
"Jäger des verlorenen Schatzes"
hat einige historische Bezüge.
Mit seiner Story macht es ihn
zu einem Muss-man-gesehen-haben-Film.
Ich fand ihn großartig.
Was ist euer liebster Film
aus der "Indiana Jones"-Reihe?
Schreibt es mir.
*Fanfaren-Musik*
In "Indiana Jones
und der letzte Kreuzzug"
lernt Indy in New York
Walter Donovan kennen.
Einen reichen Industriellen,
der den Heiligen Gral sucht.
Der Kelch,
aus dem Jesus getrunken haben soll.
Der verspricht im Film Macht,
Erlösung und v.a. ewiges Leben.
Für sein Ziel
kooperiert Donovan mit den Nazis.
Er ist der verkörperte Kapitalismus,
das pure eigennützige Böse.
(leise) Donovan.
Didn't I warn you
not to trust anybody?
Mirko, sag mal,
haben sich Spielberg & Co.
die Figur von Donovan nur ausgedacht?
Oder gibt es
eine historische Vorlage?
Es wäre schön,
wenn Donovan nur Fiktion wäre.
Aber leider gab es viele wie ihn
rund um den Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Als die USA in den Krieg eintraten,
gab es dagegen viel Widerstand.
Nicht wenige hielten Roosevelt
für eine Marionette der Verschwörung
jüdischer Bankiers.
Das war kompletter Blödsinn.
Einige Jahre existierte in New York
ein Zweig des Amerikanischen Bundes.
Eine nationalsozialistische Gruppe.
Ich kann mir vorstellen:
Die, die Indy zu Donovan bringen,
gehörten genau zu diesem Bund.
Okay, wow.
Damit haben wir
die Figur von Donovan geklärt.
Aber wenn es viele wie ihn gab,
wie viele waren das in den USA?
Wie öffentlich sind die aufgetreten?
Das war kein Einzelfall.
Anfang der 1930er-Jahre
wurde in den USA die Organisation
"Friends of New Germany" gegründet.
Sie wollte den Frieden zwischen
Deutschland und den USA fördern.
Sie sorgte für Aufsehen,
weil sie großflächig propagierte,
dass Juden über Deutschlands Taten
Lügen verbreiten würden.
Es kam zum Boykott deutscher Waren
und zu einer Ermittlung.
Hitler wurde klar,
dass die "Friends of New Germany"
ungewollte Aufmerksamkeit erregten.
Er befahl allen Deutschen,
sich aus der Gruppe zurückzuziehen.
Die Gruppe sollte erscheinen wie eine
dt.-amerikanische Basisorganisation.
Hitler setzte deshalb
den eingebürgerten Amerikaner
Fritz Kuhn als Leiter ein.
Kuhn hielt Hitler
für Deutschlands Retter
und sich selbst für Amerikas Führer.
Er richtete das "Camp Siegfried" ein.
Dort konnten Deutsch-Amerikaner
Lederstiefel anziehen
und für den Tag
der Regierungsübernahme trainieren.
Kinder in Uniformen marschierten
in militärischer Formation
an ihrem Führer vorbei,
ihre Arme zum Hitlergruß erhoben.
Ähnliche Camps wurden
in anderen US-Städten gegründet.
Kuhns größter Triumph
war eine Versammlung
im New Yorker Madison Square Garden.
Daran nahmen 1939
20.000 Menschen teil.
Eingebettet in Hakenkreuze.
Vor dem Krieg
war es in den USA kein Verbrechen,
Nazi zu sein
und Hitler zu unterstützen.
Deshalb gibt es prominente Beispiele.
Sowohl in der Wirtschaft,
z.B. der Automogul Henry T. Ford,
als auch in der Politik,
wie Joe Kennedy oder Prescott Bush.
Der Großvater von George W. Bush
arbeitete nach dem Kriegseintritt,
als es schon wichtige Informationen
über die Pläne der Nazis gab,
weiter für Unternehmen,
die Hitlers Aufstieg finanzierten.
Und er profitierte von ihnen.
Mindestens einer der Ankläger
von Nazi-Kriegsverbrechen meinte:
Bushs Taten
hätten als Unterstützung des Feindes
strafrechtlich
verfolgt werden sollen.
Er deutete an:
Bush legte mit den Geschäften
die Basis für das Familienvermögen.
Und half,
die Bushs als Dynastie zu etablieren.
Profiteure
der Nationalsozialisten in den USA
wie Walter Donovan
gab es also zur Genüge.
Also auch "Indiana Jones
und der letzte Kreuzzug"
hat sich ordentlich
historisch inspirieren lassen.
Der Film spielt um das Jahr 1938.
Von da aus reisen wir
jetzt 30 Jahre in die Zukunft.
In die Zeit des Kalten Krieges,
ins Jahr 1969.
*Fanfaren-Musik*
Im neuen Film "Rat des Schicksals"
geht es um die 1. Mondlandung.
Der Sieg der USA gegen Russland
im Space Race
offenbart für Indy
unangenehme Wahrheiten.
Die haben v.a. mit ihm zu tun,
Jürgen Voller.
Hitler made mistakes.
With this I will correct them all.
Das ist ein Ex-Nazi,
der von der NASA
in den USA angeheuert wurde.
Das ergibt Sinn.
Deutsche Ingenieurstechnik
hatte damals schon einen guten Ruf.
Oder, Mirko?
Ja, so ist es.
Zur Mondlandung im Jahr 1969
arbeiteten über 100 dt. Techniker
und Ingenieure für die NASA.
Nicht alles Nationalsozialisten,
z.T. aber zumindest ehemalige.
Es handelte sich u.a.
um spezialisierte Wissenschaftler,
die unter Hitler die Waffentechnik
revolutioniert hatten.
Der Schurke Jürgen Voller
basiert wohl in Teilen
auf dem Ingenieur Wernher von Braun.
Der hatte erst für die Nazis
mächtige Raketen gebaut,
darunter die V2.
Bei der Produktion
starben tausende Zwangsarbeiter.
Später entwickelte er
Raketen für die NASA.
Darunter die Saturn-Raketen,
die Menschen auf den Mond brachten.
Von Brauns Faszination für den Mond
reicht zurück in seine Jugend.
Mit 17 schrieb er eine Geschichte
mit dem Titel "Lunetta".
Zu deutsch "Das Möndchen".
Darin wird der Erdtrabant
mit Atomwaffen bestückt,
um Weltfrieden zu erzwingen.
Für die Verwirklichung dieses Traums
war ihm jedes Mittel recht.
Er behauptete:
"Wissenschaft an sich
besitzt keine moralische Dimension."
Von Braun musste sich nie
für seine NS-Vergangenheit
verantworten.
Er erfreute sich stattdessen
in den USA großer Popularität.
Das ist heftig, zeigt aber auch,
dass es eine konkrete Person
als Vorlage für den Film gab.
Auch wenn der sonst
kein Historienfilm sein möchte.
Denn, Nazis beiseite:
"Indiana Jones"-Filme
sollen v.a. unterhalten.
Sie haben v.a. eines zu bieten:
knallharte Action.
*Filmmusik "Indiana Jones"*
Großer Dank an Mirko fürs Erklären.
Seid so lieb, flitzt rüber zu ihm,
lasst ein paar Grüße von uns da.
Vielleicht ein Peitschenknallen
in die Kommentare.
Mit einem P.S.,
dann weiß er, dass es von uns kommt.
Schreibt hier in die Kommentare,
ob ihr euch Teil 5 anschaut.
Oder ob ihr sagt:
"Die ersten 3
sind die wahren Indy-Filme."
Drückt auf "abonnieren"
und aktiviert die Glocke,
dann können wir uns bald wiedersehen.
Bis dahin, ciao.
Wenn ihr wissen wollt,
ob sich der neue Teil lohnt,
schaut bei Robert Hoffmann vorbei,
der eine Filmkritik gemacht hat.
Hier unten gibt es was von uns.
Es beschäftigt sich damit,
warum Indy bester Schatzjäger,
aber beschissenster Mathematiker ist.